firefighters from istanbul have arrived
just in the nick of time but they are
vastly outnumbered by the villagers of
childhood may who are desperately trying
to halt the flames
laughing at their back gardens
everyone who can is healthy in the
effort
many are terrified but this is about
saving their homes and all their
possessions
and time is not on their side this is
quite an
extraordinary local effort these are
just villagers without
any training just a desire to beat back
the planes from their homes
they use water bottles to dampen the
area around their houses
it's all they have but there's another
breakout on the other side of the
village
the fires moving in on them on several
sides
and many villagers are bitterly critical
their government wasn't better prepared
i feel very tired and helpless we can't
do
anything our houses are burning
our forests are burning and there's
nothing we can do
the state isn't helping if the villagers
weren't here it would be worse
there aren't enough fire fighters there
no planes there are no helicopters
where are these people she's screaming
there's growing anger
the help isn't coming quickly enough for
them these fires have gone on for nearly
a week now
[Music]
my house is burning my house my house my
god she tells us
where are they where are they
this village is standing in the path of
the fire
and they just can't seem to stop its
advance
these are the worst fires in at least a
decade in turkey with the whole of the
mediterranean suffering higher than
normal temperatures
the fire is completely out running
firefighters it's
totally engulfed at this house and is
taking over and about to burn
tractors and farmland it is outpacing
firefighters
at a rate of knots and they just can't
keep place of it
we saw one farmer desperately throwing
buckets of water around
not nearly enough to staunch this angry
fire
a russian helicopter was helping out
trying to douse the flames
part of the international help offered
after the turkish leader admitted his
air fleet was not adequate
panic is building up and at a rapid rate
the fire is advancing and the winds are
picking up
helping it rip through the surrounding
forest
as the firefighters decide to pull out
they warn everyone to do the same
their plan is to return with
reinforcements but right now the fire's
too strong
and people are scrambling to get to
safety
this is what they're up against because
this has happened within the last 20
minutes
get out get out they're shouting there's
no clarity on exactly how these fires
started
although some have been blamed on
arsonists but the forests are tinder dry
after these record temperatures
and the ferocity of the fires have been
shocking
look at that sheet of flames and that
has happened
within minutes and now it's coming from
both sides
and it's moving this way wow
that is wow turkey has already been
suffering badly economically because of
coronavirus and the fall in tourism
these fires will deliver yet another
cruel punch and they're not over yet
alex crawford sky news in southern
turkey